[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 primer programa de este año nuevo de
2023 que se inicia con nuevo mandato de
Lula en Brasil y a partir de ahí nos
preguntamos si esto si esto confirma una
ola de izquierdas en la región lo vamos
a plantear hoy a nuestros cuatro
invitados les presento ya a Benjamín que
es corresponsal en Caracas
corresponsable del servicio
Internacional del diario Liberación
bienvenido Benjamín Buenos días gracias
por la invitación María José zorrilla
politóloga Master en comparación y
desarrollo en América Latina por el
instituto de altos estudios sobre
América Latina bienvenida María José
Muchas gracias
especializado en Latinoamérica
bienvenida Buenos días y mi compañero
David gormezano periodista en France 24
excorresponsable en Brasil bienvenido
David Hola Carlos 202 arranca con nuevo
mandato del incombustible Lula en Brasil
o en nuestro asunto en Primera Plana
[Música]
el izquierdista Lula a sus 77 años ha
vuelto al poder en Brasil con el año
nuevo en su primer discurso tras ser
investido prometió reconstruir el país
tras los años del ultraderechista
bolsonaro y anunció que Brasil está de
vuelta en la escena internacional el
nuevo mandato de Lula refuerza la
tendencia de más gobiernos de izquierdas
en la región pero no parece un izquierda
homogénea sino con varios puntos de
vista respecto a asuntos como la
democracia recordemos también el año
pasado El Triunfo de Gustavo Petro que
se convirtió el primer presidente de
izquierdas en la historia de Colombia a
partir del caso de Lula el último en
llegar vamos a poner luces de fondo para
analizar si se trata de una tendencia o
no tanto antes repasemos algunas
portadas diario o globo Lula promete
reconstruir el país de todos y
democracia para siempre lemundo
investido Lula quiere verse como el
presidente de la unidad desde Argentina
la nación Lula inició una nueva era con
fuertes críticas al legado de y en
España el país las cinco primeras
economías de América Latina están
gobernadas por primera vez por la
izquierda Bueno pues empecemos por el
último en llegar al club Lula inicia
mandato en 2023 benjamá que
destacaríamos de sus primeros pasos qué
señales ha enviado Lula en estos
primeros pasos bueno primero muestra que
Brasil está de vuelta al mundo va a
salir de su isla de su insolación
exactamente y ya tiene previsto creo
tres visitas oficiales afuera una en
Argentina primero al finales de enero
también en Estados Unidos y a Portugal y
las primeras medidas que ha tomado son
medidas para rechazar al legado de
bolsonaro pero no tanto o sea tiene una
posición bastante difícil porque tienen
que cambiar las cosas que han hecho
bolsonaro pero sin mostrarse como en una
oposición radical a lo que hizo porque
tiene un país polarizado
muchos brasileros que no quieren a Lula
y van a tener que gobernar con eso es
este país muy dividido claro lo hemos
visto en las portadas María José Lula
promete reconstruir un país que parece
irreconciliable cómo va a hacerlo claro
yo creo que justamente el mensaje
principal de Lula a nivel de en Brasil
va a ser justamente esto la unidad como
sabes recordemos que esta campaña
presidencial ha estado fuertemente
polarizada claro por grupos de extrema
derecha los militares de nuevo este
fantasma de regreso a la Dictadura y por
otro lado tenemos claro el grupo de Lula
con una nueva con un posicionamiento
hacia una nueva izquierda y creo que
justamente Lula va a tratar de
como dices amistar Estos este Brasil
esto 115 millones de brasileños a través
de por ejemplo en nombramientos de
diferentes ministros esta semana Lula
nombró cinco ministros afro
afrodescendientes y 11 mujeres entre las
cuales
Exacto entre las cuales una de ellas es
la hermana de Mariel Franco entonces hay
de nuevo esta oportunidad de reconstruir
la democracia en Brasil
hay algunos temas vistos desde fuera
sabin en los que sí que parece que haber
un cambio de tendencia uno claro es la
amazonía no la amazonía Yo diría que se
aleje principal de Lula con su nuevo
mandato y apoyándose en todo en todos
los países vecinos y en
programas que van a llegar muy pronto de
colaboración Especialmente con Colombia
porque se habló con el tuvo el Lula Tuvo
una cita con con Gustavo Petro al día
siguiente de su de su toma de Posesión Y
decidieron organizar una Cumbre para la
amazonía donde participarían los 11
países que tienen territorio amazónico Y
eso es un una urgencia porque lo que
encuentra Lula como situación en la
amazonía es peor de lo que tenía cuando
tomo posesión en 2003 que logró revertir
a lo largo de los años y que ahora fue
completamente
destrozado por la política de bochonado
Mientras tanto este eje prioritario de
la amazonía y de recuperar la
biodiversidad
luchar contra la deforestación
se va a enfrentar a los gobiernos de
ciertos estados amazónicos brasileños
que están del lado de bolsonado que
están del lado de la explotación del
agro de mineral ilegal de la amazonía
David claro es que este Brasil no es el
mismo que el entre 2003 y 2010
Lula En qué se debe diferenciar Por
decirlo de alguna forma Lula 1 de Lula 2
el número uno era el candidato del
partido de los trabajadores con su
historia su trayectoria y el Lula del
2023 es el Lula de una coalición
democrática que va de partidos de la
extrema izquierda hasta partidos de la
derecha conservadora cuyo primer
objetivo era estar a bolsonaro pero
ahora hace falta gobernar y ahora uno de
los desafíos de de Lula es de mantener
esa coalición democrática unida sobre un
tiempo largo porque el congreso
brasileño está muy a la derecha y el
peso de los diputados bolsonaristas o
exvocionalistas Y de lo que los
brasileños hablan central
estos partidos
que no son centristas son son muy
vinculados a intereses del del
agronegocio o religioso
y muy oportunistas bueno
tienen la mayoría de dos tercios para
provocar un nuevo impeachment una nueva
destitución de de un presidente
Así que si Lula no mantiene la unidad de
su coalición tiene ese esa amenaza de
destitución como pasó con Dilma
tremendo vamos a tener que estar muy
pendientes de ello
darán Lula y Petro una mayor proyección
América Latina en 2023 O al menos una
mayor coordinación interna
yo creo que los dos quieren realmente
impulsar a una dinámica de de
cooperación regional más fuerte que al
final nunca realmente existió la cosa es
que los dos van a querer ser líderes de
esa
impulsión regional yo creo que Lula
tiene un peso muy fuerte porque tiene ya
experiencia viene de otra generación y
ya tiene ese esa figura del compromiso y
eso creo que va a ayudar también en
interno y Pedro quiere impulsar otra
visión quizás una visión más
más actual de la izquierda vamos a ver
como los dos pueden hablar pueden tratar
y ese cumbre en amazonas va a ser súper
interesante sobre eso porque van a
llegar muchos otros países como
Venezuela Y ese tema de mensual puede
ser interesante en eso normalmente
Francia también y Francia también tiene
territorio
una mayor proyección en América Latina
Pues yo creo que justamente hay como
como
señala cierta competencia dentro de
quién se va a volver la nueva figura o
el nuevo líder en esta nueva izquierda
en América Latina y me parece que por
ejemplo no sé una de las nuevas figuras
que está resurgiendo es el la figura del
presidente chileno Eh entonces Creo que
todavía son diferentes maneras de ver
ciertas políticas sociales en la región
pero creo que al final Todavía es muy
pronto para poder responderlo para
hablar de proyección hacia el mundo
América Latina Quizá es pronto pero para
hablar de una mejor coordinación interna
como hablábamos con Benjamín puede
funcionar coordinación interna dentro de
la región de la región sí Lula ya
anunció que quería revitalizar muchos
muchas instituciones
interregionales que bolsonaro
ignoraba totalmente como el celac y la
unasur mercosur Ahora son intenciones
Porque al fin y al cabo la los países de
la región
si hablamos de México por ejemplo tienen
intereses incluso económicos e
intraorregionales un poco divergentes a
veces los hay que se acercan más a China
al eje hacia Pacífico y los hay que
quieren abrir y acercarse más a Estados
Unidos y Canadá y Unión Europea como
decía Benjamín en analistas que señalan
que el único líder que tiene esa
capacidad de unir a la región en
desafíos comunes es Lula Aunque otros
gobiernos quieran no tienen el peso de
Brasil ni la experiencia del presidente
Lula no sé si está de acuerdo a David
Bueno al mismo tiempo muchos países de
latinoamérica
temen un poco de Brasil por por el
tamaño de la economía brasileña en el
mercosur una de las
de por cual el mercosur está estancado
es que es un país de más de 200 millones
de habitantes es un poder es un poder
económico muy grande y las otras
economías
latinoamericanas son más chicas en
Argentina por ejemplo
un periodo de construcción del mercosur
la industria Argentina
desapareció unos unos sectores
desaparecieron porque la industria
brasileña era más competitiva así que
el económico es muy importante
pero también genera temores por el por
la magnitud que tiene Brasil y por el
otro lado también está ahí México que
quiere competir con Brasil y con el peso
de Brasil y pero con otras decisiones
con otros Socios con la llegada de Lula
el poder las cinco principales potencias
de la región Brasil México Argentina
chile y Colombia están gobernadas por la
izquierda algo que es una novedad al
mismo tiempo Benjamín esto es síntoma de
algo o hacer el análisis grupal en
bloque es un error es complicado porque
hay factores que se aplican a cada país
y hay factores globales yo creo que la
pandemia es un factor interesante porque
muchas poblaciones de latinoamérica se
dieron cuenta que se necesitaba un
estado fuerte un estado Social para
enfrentar a crisis como como esa crisis
sanitaria pero también al mismo tiempo
hay un rechazo global a una forma de
política política que que no funcionó en
los años 2010 y después hay también
cosas realmente bueno que que dependen
de cada país por ejemplo lo que pasó en
Chile nace de un movimiento social lo
que pasó en Brasil es una reacción al
bolsonarismo lo que pasó en Colombia es
diferente también
de la izquierda en Colombia es decir son
cosas distintas No
esas dinámicas globales yo creo que
tienen mucho que ver con el económico y
después dinámicas internas de política
de gestión social que son diferentes
vamos a seguir analizando si se está
produciendo o no una ola de izquierdas
en América Latina con la llegada de Lula
al poder Pero va a ser a vuelta de esta
pequeña pausa hasta ahora
[Música]
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en France 24 y France 24.com
seguimos en Primera Plana esta semana
analizando con la llegada de Lula al
poder recién estrenado mandato en 2023
si se está produciendo una ola de
izquierdas en América Latina Y a partir
de ahí si ese análisis se puede efectuar
en bloque o no O quizá no lo hacemos con
Benjamín es corresponsal en Caracas
María José zorrilla politóloga sabin
grandan periodista independiente y David
gormezano periodista de aquí de France
24 que fue corresponsal en Brasil antes
de la pausa estamos hablando con
Benjamín que quizá hay algunas
características algunas cosas que sí que
podamos utilizar en para todo para toda
América Latina como causas de esta ola
de izquierdas y luego hay realidades
específicas de cada país No sé si está
de acuerdo María José David
diría que hay otro elemento que
contribuye a que haya una ola de
izquierda en Latinoamérica a pesar de
que pienso que también es una cuestión
de oportunidades de alternancia pero es
la toma de conciencia si me puedo
expresar así de la opinión pública de lo
que se debe esperar de una acción de
estado de la cosa de los servicios
públicos de la justicia social de
las ayudas y
el sostén del estado en las pensiones en
la en la distribución de los recursos O
sea yo creo que las opiniones públicas
de América Latina están tomando mucha
después de los estallidos sociales que
hubo de que el estado tiene que
intervenir Y esa es una cosa desde desde
gobiernos sociodemocratas lo enlazo con
la pandemia Eso quiere decir que la
tendencia hacia la izquierda responde en
parte a una mayor sensibilidad tener
servicios
sanitarios por ejemplo de calidad
derivados de la pandemia de la covid
David Sí claro la pandemia tiene tiene
un impacto muy fuerte sobre sobre bueno
la elección en Brasil seguramente y en
otros países también
esta ola de gobierno de de izquierda Me
parece
intervenir un contexto muy diferente de
los años 2000 Claro porque crecimiento
de
niveles más o menos no va a ocurrir en
los próximos años
y también en los años 2000 había una
voluntad de oponerse a Estados Unidos
en pleno guerra de Irak en ese en esa
década y y ahora no no veo una unidad
latinoamericana fuerte como como en los
años 2000 para tener una voz común en el
escenario mundial quizá esas izquierdas
también son distintas analizándolo claro
Lula se acerca más a la generación de
amlo que a la de borics ideológicamente
también María José Claro Mira yo pienso
que definitivamente es saludable para la
democracia que haya este cierto péndulo
del poder hacia la izquierda y claro y
como te como como te comentaba es para
mí representa justamente esta nueva
imagen de una nueva izquierda con nuevas
propuestas por ejemplo
interesados más en las luchas feministas
en las luchas medioambientales en las
luchas lgtbi etcétera entonces creo que
es una nueva forma de de tratar estos
nuevos temas sociales con una Pues con
una nueva perspectiva les pregunto por
lo que tenían enfrente estos candidatos
de izquierdas Porque muchos de ellos han
ganado candidatos de extrema derecha en
América Latina En qué se diferencian
esos candidatos de extrema derecha a los
europeos En qué se diferencia se extrema
derecha de América Latina la de Europa
yo creo que hay algo con la nostalgia a
la Dictadura es algo un poco raro porque
son candidatos como que sea bolsonaro o
por ejemplo en Chile que han nacido de
la Democracia pero que llegan con un
discurso de nostalgia a algo de orden
más fuerte llegan con un discurso muy
populista muy antisistema y creo que
nacen también de esa ola de corrupción
que hubo en América Latina desde el
principio de los años 2000 y juega
aunque a veces sean inculpados o tienen
vínculos con con corrupción llegan con
un discurso para decir sacamos a todo
ese ese sistema político y vamos a a
poner orden de nuevo aunque no lo hacen
Aunque
destruyen a todo como lo hizo bolsonaro
llegan de eso de esa dinámica de con el
caso de brecha que que hubo en Brasil y
en toda América Latina yo creo que nacen
de eso no es realmente el el mismo
síntoma que Europa es algo muy
latinoamericano porque el bolsonarismo
David Estamos de acuerdo ha llegado no
se va a ir con la con la llegada de
lularismo va a quedarse en Brasil con o
sin bolsonaro Y eso es muy interesante
va a volver bolsonaro de Estados Unidos
en los próximos próxima semanas meses va
a quedarse ahí en Estados Unidos
el bolsonarismo va
sin bolsonaro puede existir con quién
eso lo vamos a ver en los próximos meses
pero
es seguro que si de nuevo la situación
económica empeora en Brasil
el sudarismo va a abordar con con mucha
fuerza volviendo al tema de las
diferentes izquierdas una de las
principales cualidades que puede tener
una izquierda nueva como la de borics es
romper ese bloque homogéneo que en algún
momento
bueno varios de ellos defendían a hacha
decía y al régimen cubano en alguna
ocasión Boris representa esa una figura
de esa izquierda o es el estandarte es
izquierda que es crítica con Venezuela y
con Cuba claro y de esa forma también se
padece a un Lula a un amlo and López
Obrador en México o sea son regímenes
que
se basan en lo concreto en la en las
acciones concretas y que se han alejado
de de un discurso más ideológico y
tienden yo diría que tienen una una
dimensión común que es precisamente ese
esa obligación absoluta de construir
políticas de lucha contra el
calentamiento global que les toca a
todos los países latinoamericanos y que
es una una dimensión transversal que
inicia e inspira medidas comunes dentro
de un marco de ayuda a las poblaciones
de restablecimiento de la justicia
social y de los pueblos indígenas por
ejemplo o sea este eje
transcurre en todos los países que a
quienes toca el calentamiento global es
decir a todos María José la izquierda
latinoamericana ya no saqué el bloque
que defendía en su momento a Chávez y a
los Castro definitivamente la izquierda
cambió en estos 20 20 años desde los
años 2000 Entonces sí yo creo que hay
una nueva forma de reconfigurarse a la
izquierda una nueva forma de
replantearse estos estas nuevas
problemáticas pero también como lo hemos
señalado siento que la mayoría ahorita
del líder de izquierda son bastante
pragmáticos O sea no siento que podamos
realmente Llamar a uno como Pues un
social demócratas o izquierdas
tradicionales siento que cada uno va a
estar jugando los intereses que les
corresponde para sus países mirando el
año Uy David si algo más me vas a decir
quiero volver los años 2000 sé que hubo
hasta ola de gobierno de izquierda y
muchos fracasaron y yo creo que los
nuevos líderes han aprendido de este
fracaso y que y que las batallas cultura
en los países latinoamericanos
y pensaban que las habían ganado y se
dieron cuenta con la vuelta de una
derecha aún más extrema que que antes
Que no que la batalla cultural la
izquierda no la ganó y que todavía y que
ahora Estamos en en países que son muy
fracturados muy polarizados mucho más
que 20 años atrás y que ahora perdón
pero no funciona el enfrentamiento al
otro lado ideológico hay una cultura de
compromiso que se que se instaló en la
izquierda creo lo vemos con con
Venezuela ahora lo que dice Pedro lo que
dice Lula es vamos a tratar de dialogar
cambia muchísimo con lo que pasó con el
grupo de Lima que era un grupo de de los
dirigentes de derecha
cuyo objetivo era sacar a maduro ahora
no dicen esto lo condenan como lo hizo
Boris pero dicen Tenemos que dialogar
porque el principal reto de eso es que
hay seis millones de venezolanos que han
salido del país y ese esa presión
migratoria muy fuerte en América Latina
es un interés global de bueno responder
a esa presión
volviendo al tema del manejo de las
izquierdas actuales en Latinoamérica
también
una diferencia
en cuanto a los años 2000 es que tienen
a opiniones públicas más agudas
hubieron estallidos sociales hay muchos
movimientos
activismo y las opiniones públicas están
esperando Mucho en cuanto al papel del
Estado dentro de un marco democrático es
decir como lo decíamos antes los
servicios públicos justicia social me
queda muy pocos minutos pero a modo de
pinceladas agenda política 2023 en
América Latina vamos estar pendientes de
muchas cosas pero entre ellas muy
importantes las elecciones en Argentina
te voy a preguntar David y también cómo
van a continuar algunas crisis abiertas
como es el caso de la de Perú como veis
lo principal en pinceladas que tenemos
que tener el ojo Argentina Bueno qué va
a pasar Argentina en 10 meses primero en
junio en los argentinos van a hay un
sistema que se llama el los pasos y van
a elegir candidatos van a medir el peso
de diferentes candidatos y [__] vamos a
ver si el del lado del peronismo
Encuentran una fórmula como la fórmula
que permitió la elección de Alberto
Fernández con Cristina Fernández de
kirchner vicepresidenta los dos se
pelearon mucho en los últimos años
Cristina Fernández Fue condenada en un
caso de corrupción en diciembre
y mucho queda de este lado del panorama
político en Argentina
si el peronismo va a poder inventar una
nueva fórmula para competir en la
próxima elección María José Benjamín dos
pinceladas año 2023 Bueno sobre todo
para Perú Me parece que ha habido una
crisis como ya sabemos una crisis
política sostenida durante todos estos
años y ahora justamente con pues la
destitución del presidente
castillo y ahora nombramiento de Dina
boluarte las cosas en Perú está más
antes bastante complicadas y se espera
pues una nueva nueva nuevas elecciones
generales en de acá del 2024 y pues
estábamos esperando una nueva
constitución pero pues Lamentablemente
el sistema político el ambiente político
no es fructífero pues no me da tiempo
para más estaremos muy atentos en 2023 a
estos asuntos Muchísimas gracias por
haber compartido con nosotros nuestro
primer programa como Lula de 2023 y a
todos ustedes le esperamos la próxima
semana quien en Primera Plana gracias
[Música]